The term quantum teleportation may sound like the stuff of science fiction, but as we'll talk about in today's episode
of Kiskit in the Classroom, it's a very real and very useful technique for quantum communication and
networking. Welcome to Qiskit in the classroom. In the series, we'll use Qiskit to explore some fundamental
concepts commonly covered in quantum computing related courses. Each video is accompanied by an interactive module
linked in the description below, so be sure to check it out. Teleportation is kind of a science fiction and fantasy
trope at this point. A person or object disappears from one location and instantaneously appears somewhere else.
As cool as this would be, unfortunately, this kind of teleportation at least is impossible. It would break the cosmic
speed limit. Nothing can travel faster than light. But quantum teleportation is
possible. In quantum teleportation, information rather than matter can be transmitted between two
distant locations. All you need is a pair of entangled particles, one at each site, and a way to communicate classical
information between the two sites. This protocol was developed in 1993 by a team
of quantum scientists, including IBM's Charles Bennett. They called it quantum teleportation because similar to the
science fiction version, the quantum information disappeared from one location and appeared in another distant
location without ever traveling through the intervening space. It may sound like magic, but as we'll see, there's nothing
mysterious or magic about it. It's enabled by the phenomenon of quantum entanglement along with classical
communication. Today we're going to walk through the quantum teleportation protocol and how it works. And then we'll put it into
action on a real quantum computer to teleport the state of a cubit from one side of an IBM quantum processor to
another. So here's how a quantum teleportation works. Suppose we have two people Alice and Bob who are separated
by a large distance. Say Alice has a cubit. We'll call cubit Q just for convenience. And it's in some
unknown quantum state sq where alpha 0 and alpha 1 are complex
numbers. Alice wants to send her state to Bob, but she has no way to actually send the cubit itself. It could be that
he's too far away, or maybe she doesn't even know exactly where Bob is, so she doesn't know where to send it. Luckily,
the friends already share a pair of entangled cubits A and B, where Alice has cubit A and Bob has cubit B. And
these cubits are entangled. By entangled, I mean that even though the two cubits are separated by a large
distance, their states are correlated in a way that classical physics cannot account for. This entangled pair is
something called an Ebit, which we can use as a resource in quantum computing and communication.
In this case, Alice can use the EBIT as a resource to transmit her quantum information to Bob. To see how, let's
start by writing out the joint state of all three of these cubits where I've ordered the cubits somewhat arbitrarily
at this point, but this ordering will be convenient when we run our experiment on Kiskit. In Qiskit, the standard way to
order the cubits is right to left. So, the state of cubit zero will appear on the right.
Let's expand the state a little bit and rewrite it like this. Then the first step in our teleportation protocol is
for Alice to entangle her data cubit with her half of the EBIT cubit using a C knot gate. A C knot or controlled KN
gate will change the state of one cubit, the target cubit, depending on the state of another cubit, the control cubit.
If the control cubit is in the state zero, then nothing happens to the target. And if the control cubit's in
the state one, then the target cubit is flipped. So in this case, Alice's data cubit Q will be the control cubit and
her Ebit cubit A will be the target cubit. So the first two terms didn't change at all by the C knot, but the
last two terms did because the control cubit Q was in the state one. Then Alice
would apply a hatamard gate to her data cubit Q which takes the state 0 to the state 1 /2 0 + 1 and the state 1 to
1 over 2 0 -1. I'm going to skip some simple algebra here which you can try to fill in on your own if you want.
But after rearranging some terms you'll get a state that looks like this. So now Alice and Bob's three cubit
entangled state looks like a complete mess. But look what happens if Alice measures both her cubits. The three
cubit state will partially collapse to one of these four
terms. And in each case, Bob will be left with a superposition state with amplitudes that are related to Alice's
initial unknown state. Remember the amplitudes are alpha 0 and alpha 1. So
for example, if Alice measures both cubits to be zero, then Bob's state will collapse to this term, the original
unknown state that Alice wanted to teleport. But if Alice measures zero on cubit A and one on cubit Q, then Bob's
state will be this one. This state can be transformed into the original state of cubit Q if Bob
applies a Zgate, which will flip this sign here. But Bob won't know to do this
until he learns what Alice has measured. So the next step in the protocol is for Alice to call up Bob and tell him what
her two measurements were. After he knows that, he'll know what operations to perform on his cubit to make it match
Alice's original state. Here's a table of the four possible measurements and the four possible operations that Bob
will need to perform on his cubit based on those measurements. Bob might need to perform a Zgate, an Xgate, or both to
transform his cubit to match Alice's original cubit. This last step, where Alice calls Bob, by the way, is why
quantum teleportation doesn't violate causality. Even though Bob's state instantly collapsed when Alice measured
her cubits, Bob couldn't get any information out of that state until Alice told Bob what she measured. And
that call was limited by the speed of light. We just went through a lot of detailed math, so the incredible fact
that we just teleported quantum information may have gotten lost. But it's really pretty amazing. By using
entanglement as a resource, Alice could make a measurement to destroy quantum information stored with her and have it
appear in another distant location with Bob. This distance could be hundreds, even thousands of kilometers. Even more
amazingly, this protocol doesn't even require that Alice know exactly where Bob is. As long as they share an Ebit
and they can classically communicate with one another, quantum teleportation will work. Now, let's see how this works
with Qiskit and actually teleport a quantum state on a quantum computer.
We'll start with three cubits, one each for the data cubit Q and the cubits A and B that will make up the E bit. We
start by creating the E bit. We apply a hatamard on cubit A followed by a C knot
between A and B to create the entangled state we're after.
Then we prepare Alice's cubit Q in a random quantum state by applying a random unitary shown by this box labeled
U. Then comes the teleportation. First the C knot between cubits Q and A. Then the hat had on
cubit Q. Then the measurements partially collapse the state so that only Bob's cubit B is in a superp position.
This is the point at which Alice would call Bob up and tell him what she measured. Then Bob would apply some
gates depending on those measurements. These red outlined boxes signify conditional gates. The first one means
that Bob applies an X gate to his cubit if cubit A is measured to be one. And
the second means he'll apply a Zgate also if cubit Q is measured to be one.
So now Bob should have a cubit in the same state that Alice's cubit was in at this point here after the unitary gate.
If all went according to plan, then we have teleported the quantum state. But how do we check that? We can run the
same circuit but make one small change.
Here we've added another unitary at the very end of the circuit applied to Bob's cubit. This unitary is the inverse of
the one we applied at the beginning to Alice's cubit. The reasoning here is that if this first gate created the
quantum state that is now teleported to Bob's cubit, then this one should undo it, taking Bob's cubit back to the zero
state. But of course, this undoes all of our hard work of teleporting the state in the first place. So we wouldn't want
to do this if we actually wanted to do something with the teleported state and if it were truly in an unknown quantum
state, we wouldn't be able to apply a unitary to undo it. Anyway, this is purely for diagnostic purposes to make
sure that teleportation was successful. If we measure Bob's cubit to be in the zero state, then we can be reasonably
sure that teleportation worked. Once we're sure that our protocol is working as expected, then we could remove this
final unitary and actually do something with the teleported state. But for now, let's just make sure it works. Let's
execute the circuit on a quantum computer. We can use the kisskit primitive sampler to run this circuit
many times and gather statistics on the measurement outcomes. If we perfectly teleported Alice's state to Bob every
time, then Bob would measure his cubit to be zero every time, but with environmental noise and imperfections in
the gates, we can expect to see some runs where Bob's cubit ends up being one. But as long as the majority of the
time Bob's cubit is measured to be zero, we can call it a success. Here we have a histogram of the measurement outcomes of
all three cubits. Bob's measurement is shown to be the first slot of each three-bit string. As expected, the four
outcomes that correspond to his bit being zero are much more likely than the other four. So, we have successfully
teleported a quantum state. But look how far we teleported. This is a map of all the
cubits on the quantum processor that we used. And in the experiment, we used just these three cubits.
Alice's cubit was here and Bob's cubit was here. So, they were almost right next to each other. We could have
achieved the same thing by just applying a couple swap gates, which as the name suggests, just swaps the quantum states
of two neighboring cubits. Quantum teleportation is useful for transporting quantum information long distances, and
quantum states have been teleported hundreds of kilome before. For our experiments here, we're limited by the
size of the chip, but we could make the teleportation a little more impressive by teleporting a state between two
distant cubits on our quantum computer. So, let's try that. Here's our new circuit diagram. It looks a bit more
complicated, but nothing has fundamentally changed except that now Alice and Bob create their shared EBIT,
then separate. This series of lines and X's represent swap gates which move
Alice and Bob states from one cubit to another. Alice moves up to cubit 1 and
Bob moves down to cubit 12. Then Alice creates her random state on cubit 0 with
this unitary. Keep in mind that she's making the state after she and Bob have already
separated. So Bob is already far from her.
Then the teleportation protocol continues as before and Bob ends up with Alice's original state after his
conditional operations. We apply the inverse unitary gate and then check that Bob's cubit is
in the state zero. And again we see that the majority of the time Bob's cubit was found to be in the zero
state. So teleportation was successful.
The success rate isn't quite as high as when Alice and Bob were next to each other, though. All of those swap gates
can be expensive and cause the EBIT to degrade a bit. Quantum teleportation might seem like magic, but as we've
seen, all it takes is entanglement, a classical communication channel, and some cleverness. The original 1993
proposal that we've covered in this video formed the foundation for other protocols such as quantum gate
teleportation and is an essential ingredient for quantum computation and communications.
On the experimental front, scientists have continued to push the boundaries of quantum teleportation, even managing to teleport
the quantum state of a photon between a lab on Earth and a satellite 1,400 km
above it. And to teleport quantum states through a noisy classical internet cable. If you want to teleport your own
quantum state, head over to the quantum teleportation module linked in the description below. Thanks for watching
and I'll see you next time.